all right
we are now live for the march ama
and um i'm
dressed a little bit more formally than
than usual in part because
i was just shooting some videos on
nietzsche's
genealogy of morals because my my
students are
engaging with that in a few weeks so
we're in essay 1
as far as the stuff i'm shooting
so let's let's see we've already got a
lot of questions here let's start
running
through them um let me actually get
something out of the way to begin with
at the start
i've talked about figures that people
ask me about all the time like
you know slav or nick land
or jordan peterson or all these sort of
pop culture figures
of philosophy and so i don't you know
those are going to be low priority
questions because
i've talked about those those uh people
so often
all right mason says given your
philosophical eclecticism i wonder which
philosophers as well as other figures of
views of human nature i mean i would say
like probably hundreds
um and
part of my views on human nature are
that we don't fully understand
human nature much of the time and we're
using
models that can be more or less helpful
to understand it but we shouldn't claim
that we fully
grasp but given how reflexive human
nature is and how complex it is so i
mean
i rely on literary figures who i think
have a lot of insight
you know some of them are contemporary
we could call them contemporary uh
uh speculative fiction writers like for
example ursula kayla green and philip k
dick
you know um somebody who i'm doing this
month are scott backer i think has some
interesting insights
you know a lot of philosophers uh play
into that some psychologists
remember psychology came out of
philosophy in the first place
um so there it's it's not as if it's
totally um cut off
from it as a separate discipline
although sometimes people within the
discipline of of psychology
like to to do that just as people in in
other disciplines do so
you know there's so many figures that i
don't know that i would i would pick
any in particular zach says were you
ever rejected from any grad schools you
applied to
if so how did you get over the pain
rejections from grad schools was not
that big of an issue for me i only
applied to 10
i had no useful advice on how to do it
and
back then the gre had three different
sections to it
and i maxed out one of the sections so i
had very high scores so schools were
interested in
in letting me in um even overlooking my
totally crazy writing sample where i
took my senior thesis which was on truth
sulferential
truth self-referential statement groups
and wrote a like three-page thing about
how
the you know functional approach that i
took with it could actually
be you know analogized to a geometrical
approach which would be the you know
involve the mobius strip and and the
place where i actually did get accepted
the chair said
you know the writing sample almost
killed you um
but you had high enough scores that we
let you in because we figured there had
to be something
to what you were doing and so um
that wasn't that wasn't really the the
main issue for me
um i did have some setbacks like for
example
marquette university oh the input volume
is really low there we go let's fix that
i don't know what's up with with um
these uh um friggin uh
apple products some of the time you know
the updates get worse and worse
anyway marquette lost my letters of
recommendation
and that's a big deal you know and the
um
the chair i i met up with him later on
at a coffee house and i don't know
what's going on with the input volume
values everyone able to hear
all right because um
my my computer is acting kind of weird
with the sound thing
um maybe somebody could weigh in
very quickly before i keep going on
um was it too too soft at the start
i'm looking at the sound thing and it's
just like creeping itself downward
as i'm i'm speaking um
not quite sure what that's about well
i'll wait
okay mark says can hear me fine good um
so anyway um the uh
yeah they lost my letters or
recommendation the chair was was
really ticked off said i'll look into
this but by then the damage was done
i've encountered a lot more rejection in
terms of two other things
the job market and
publication right sometimes you can
send something in for publication and
people
are are like um you know
sound went back down again so there we
go jack it back up
you can you can put stuff in for
publication and
um it can get rejected for all sorts of
crazy reasons
sometimes um people will just say
you know um
find a reason to reject this i've seen
editors do that you know
you don't really know what's going on
with any of these things with grad
school applications with
job applications with publishing unless
you know people on the inside and if you
do you probably already have the
contacts
that are helping you out right
and that isn't the case for most of us
when it comes to job applications
i would apply sometimes for positions
and get an email back saying oh we had
you know 500 qualified
applicants uh so much of stuff in in
philosophy
and in the humanities is really based on
a stratification
that has a lot to do with class and
prestige and very little to do with
talent or anything like that
so you know the number one thing to do
when you get rejected
is to say this isn't really about me
this is about whatever
whatever decision procedure they were
carrying out
in their time that's what it's really
focused on
and i don't have control over that
i'm not responsible for how
these people make their choices
um so you know those are things that i
think you could keep in mind
um the other thing is
if you're rejected from one place that
has really nothing to do with any other
place
you know they're all doing different
things i've actually
sent uh articles out that got rejected
at one place and they're like this is
terrible stuff right
you send it out to the next place maybe
even without any modifications
they're like this is amazing right so
there's a lot of subjectivity into the
in this and i wouldn't i wouldn't take
too much
to heart it does suck to get rejected
and it might be useful to
commiserate with other people who are in
that situation
this is a particularly bad year for
getting rejected
from grad schools i i'm seeing it a lot
in my my twitter
all right gutter groan what do i think
about how leibniz
justifies the existence and
compatibility of free will with an
extreme deterministic worldview by
claiming
the perceived paradox is really a
correlation fallacy
i don't know that he says that the the
perceived paradox is a correlation
fallacy
um trying to remember exactly how he
frames it
that i think those are very late modern
terms to describe
what what leibniz himself was was doing
but you know i think leibniz so the
basic issue you're asking about here is
what do i think about leibniz is
compatibilism
i don't really like i don't think that
his like everything is is monads and
they're connected together through these
these relations in some way i don't
really buy that but
it's very interesting
i think it's well worth reading the
discourse on metaphysics and some of his
uh
like correspondence you know with with
our know and things like that
uh gmail says stan says regarding
aristotle was it you that once described
definition and scope to be two
prerequisites to his use of logic
that does not sound like me at all um
i i don't have any idea who said that
so mark asks how's it going my
department is doing a thing for the ides
of march and i was wondering if i know
any good roman recipes
i don't know any good roman recipes
myself but i do know
that they they certainly had a
wide array of things that they would
cook
and there are some some good like
cookbooks and websites out there
devoted to ancient cooking so i would go
and check those out
and you know the one thing that could be
a bit
tricky is sourcing
ingredients right because you might not
be able to get precisely
what the recipes would call for right
um kiki or what is this
kish is the bad lampshade how to deal
with intellectual insecurity
no matter how much i learn i feel like
i'm not well read enough or unqualified
to take part in discussions
because i still haven't read this or
that theorist okay so that that's a good
question
you will never have read everybody and
you will never have read
all of the essentials in any field at
this point in time
because it's just not possible and you
will have forgotten
you know 90 of what you read the first
time anyway um
so every you know that that's the bad
news
the good news is everybody's in that
that situation right
even the people who you look up to as
being like these intellectual
um you know powerhouses like i've had
the opportunity in my
career to get to meet some rock stars
of of uh philosophy right so
i got to work with aleister mcintyre for
example
and i've got i've got to meet uh julia
annas and chris gill who's one of my
colleagues in modern stoicism
and um a long i got to cross
paths with with him and um you know
quite a few other people like that as as
well
and they're all in the same boat as the
rest of us
you know nobody's read everything and if
you have conversations with them what's
cool about a lot of these
big intellectual heavy hitters as
opposed to people who
are big names but are kind of full of
themselves
is that they'll say oh yeah i didn't
know about that person at all like i got
to point out to aleister mcintyre
that there are some really interesting
parallels between his own
ideas and gabriel marcel and in the
conversation he didn't say like well you
know
because gabriel marcel got them from me
or anything well you know implausible
like that he's like
i'm gonna have to go read gabriel marcel
thanks that's that's really helpful
so you know everybody is in that same
boat of not having read
enough you might also be feeling
insecurity due to other reasons that
don't
don't respond directly to those those
sorts of cognitive
reframings and then you want to explore
that you know like sometimes
we've been told that we're stupid or
we're never going to get things
by you know parents or professors or
other people who were who were jerks in
our life and that that can have
kind of a toll on us and if if possible
you want to try to
you know work work on and work through
that sort of stuff right
um so you can take you know directly
cognitive approaches remind yourself of
the fact that
any library you walk into nobody's read
all those books
if they claim to because they were a
speed reader they're full of crap and
they don't they don't remember 90
of what it is that they speed read their
way through we're all doing kind of a
selective thing
you know um and you know the other thing
to say too is
so i mentioned academia is very prestige
written
you know um
my experience in in dealing with people
from
elite institutions is that they're no
smarter
or more talented or even often better
educated than the rest of us
they just happen to think highly of
themselves because they've been trained
that way
and doors open for them much more
naturally right
so you know if you're if you're one of
the rest of us
you can you can remind yourself hey um
it may feel scary but
what's the worst that can happen you
know maybe they i they're gonna you know
not like me
and reject me um or maybe
maybe i'm you know uh going to meet some
some new cool people you know
all right um james
asks how come uh aristotle's politics
isn't taught as much as his ethics or as
much as plato's politics my
my political philosophy classes barely
if any mentioned aristotle
i would never take your own classes
as the sample for what's going on across
the board
in in teaching right
um i i would hazard a guess to say that
within political
science departments the politics is
taught way more often than the ethics
and aristotle is taught way more often
than plato
is
we have similar things as well if you're
in
uh you know the english department
you're reading aristotle's rhetoric
and poetics more often than you're
reading the politics or the ethics
although they would both be
quite helpful to to you know put
together um
i don't i don't know that aristotle's
politics is taught less often than the
ethics
in political theory classes i can tell
you that in
ethics classes we usually focus on the
nick of mccain ethics but we usually
don't get to teach the whole of the
nicomachean ethics even
i sometimes bring in some stuff from the
politics like the discussion in book one
about
the nature of wealth you know um but
yeah it really depends on on what school
we're talking about what department
you know um here's a good question about
anti-oedipus
what concepts or philosophers should one
be familiar with before diving into
anti-oedipus
i've heard it's quite a hard book i'm
unsure if it's because the technicality
or the dense references
uh it's it's both and it's also because
it's duluz and qatari working together
so you get this weird wacky wild [ __ ]
going on you know
that that is reflective of the era that
they're in you know
um so there's a lot of stuff there's a
lot of reasons why it's difficult i mean
obviously so that it's about
freud freudianism uh so you probably
want to read some freud you probably
want to read some of the comm because
they're partially responding to
the count um but you you also
you know here's here's a good bit of
advice for any book
look at the index and see what books are
referenced the most
and you know draw upon those
as well if if you find out that
nietzsche is being referenced
on 30 pages that's probably a good sign
you want to read some nietzsche right
because he's he's being brought up a lot
so um
yeah so anti-oedipus in particular i
mean the most important thing is going
to be like
understanding uh
you know what sort of the typical
freudian approaches to things were
psychoanalytic approaches to things were
it's also important to remember
when you're reading when you're reading
uh duluz but also when you're reading
that um there's you know
psychoanalysis was done in somewhat
different ways in different places
so france itself was it became a very
doctrinaire approach to things
it was here too as well for a while
uh but but in different ways than in
france where it was so closely connected
with state power in many respects
um darth vegan
uh i just read candide and wondering if
the stoics would say we live in the best
of all possible worlds the stoics
wouldn't
i would say because they they would say
that's sort of a nonsensical question
you know could the world be made better
in in different ways
sure and then you go ahead and do it you
know
you don't have to necessarily worry
about the entirety of the
universe and how well it's it's arranged
i mean you can't
you know use providence as a way to sort
of
console yourself for when things go go
contrary to your desires and stuff but
um it's it's kind of like a cart before
the horse kind of question
you know um i mean in in large respect
too you can say the world that we live
in
from a stoic perspective is highly
reflective
of the desires and aversions
and judgments and preconceptions that we
bring to it
so you know if you're all if you're kind
of
all over the map in terms of what it is
that you desire
the world that you're involved in is
going to be awesome when you're getting
what you want and then it's going to
totally suck and it's the worst of all
worlds
when you're not getting what you want or
somebody else can control it so
i think that that's probably the kind of
approach you would want to take
towards it um
sunny asks what are some good habits to
help students become better readers of
philosophical and academic tech so
that's a great question
and i'm not going to try to give like a
comprehensive answer to that but
um i think one of the key
one of the key
skills that's needed in reading academic
texts
particularly in philosophy but also
in other disciplines as well is knowing
when the
author is presenting their position
or when somebody else with the text like
socrates and plato's dialogues is
presenting their position
and when they're presenting and
critiquing
or examining somebody else's point of
view
you know so i often have a lot of
students who mix up
what socrates is saying with what
thrasymachus is saying
and you know in republic book one right
that's that's a mistake you don't want
to make right
because then everything gets gets really
quite confused when you're reading
aristotle it's important to realize that
aristotle approaches things
dialectically which means that he looks
at what other people have to say about a
topic before
putting forth his own views
being able to so another similar
connected
skill being able to read and understand
a position without
worrying at first about whether it's
true or false
which usually winds up meaning whether
it jibes with what you're bringing
yourself already to the text
being able to actually like hear
somebody's perspective or
or you know world view or arguments
without needing to be the you know
the critic immediately you can there's
plenty of time for criticism later first
you
have to actually figure out what the
person is is saying so i think that's
that's really important um
not expecting everything to be laid on
the table
all at once is another useful skill
um you know i mentioned that i was doing
some videos on nietzsche
you know nietzsche doesn't always tell
you in a chapter
you know entitled this after doing these
particular chapters
exactly what he thinks and only what he
thinks about this topic he's all over
the map
right so you have to get used to drawing
connections between what he says over
here
what he does over here and then bringing
it together in some sort of
synthetic interpretation of your own
which might be wrong
and it might grow over time right
you know another thing too i would say
is is sort of a negative
something you don't want to do don't
draw
superficial parallelisms between things
right just because something
looks like it's doing the you know a
similar thing to this author over here
doesn't mean that they're actually doing
the same thing or that it's connected or
that you should be like drawing
going down that line rather than trying
to figure out the more
uh the more deep um connections that
might exist between things you know
and then i would i would also say too
don't rely on shitty um
histories of philosophy that
make everything out to be like well
first there's this period and everything
in this period is of this sort
and then we have this shift to this
period and that happens because of these
three factors here you know
those those are often or you know
everything is footnotes to plato
and and maybe also aristotle so
everyone's a platonist or aristotelian
those those are actually a waste of your
time those very schematic uh
arrangements they'll hold you back from
being able to see what's actually there
in the philosophical texts
all right another another good question
here uh no more baker
backer wars that's a funny
uh reference um i want there to be
another war you know i've read all seven
volumes
uh all the way to the unholy consult and
i
i don't want it to end there i want
there to be somebody fighting
for for the human human beings against
the consult
that's kind of an inside joke if you
haven't read our scott backers second
apocalypse
um series which is quite a slog
um here's the question any tips for
someone new to teaching
how does a teacher know their lessons
have been taken to heart okay so those
are two really
really interesting questions let me
answer the second one first
you never really really know
unless somebody contacts you and says
hey you know you remember that class
that that you taught um
five years ago and i was sitting there
and we were talking about this idea
i used that today you know unless unless
somebody
comes straight out and indicates these
things to you
um i i don't know that you can easily
find that that sort of thing out right
um
tips for someone new to teaching so
there's a lot of things that you could
say
one is
be willing to um
go off on side paths right
and you don't have to to stick strictly
to your lesson plan that you come
in with you can take what the students
have to say
and think through problems in the middle
of class right
oftentimes they they like that it's it's
you relating to them
um i would uh
avoid making too many pop culture
references
because they get stale pretty quickly
and you start to rely on them like so
many of my peers from my generation
invested so much of their like stick and
teaching into star trek references that
then students had no idea what the hell
they were talking about you know
um so i i you know i wouldn't i would
and i wouldn't try to be like
i'm you know i'm just like one of you i
wouldn't also give them that that sort
of like bs like i learn more
from my students than my students do for
me
because then the students will say to
you well then why aren't we getting paid
instead of you getting paid right so you
know there should be some some
recognition that you you have something
to contribute there
um there's going to be all sorts of
unforeseen circumstances that are going
to rise especially in this covid time
i would say worry less right now about
being
a disciplinarian and more about
you know your students as human beings
and whether they're getting something
out of the class that they're paying for
or not um those those are you know
this is not a very comprehensive list of
things that you could do as a teacher
but
uh hopefully they they are useful for
you
um tarshin asks what do you think is the
hardest branch of philosophy
or philosopher to understand or read i i
don't know that there is a
hardest in in like a you know like a
listing scale right different people
find different philosophers more
difficult
at different times in their life
[Music]
i know for myself uh when i was a
student there were some philosophers who
i read and i was like i can't figure out
what the hell this person is talking
about
and now i find them you know much more
easy to make sense of
um some of it also depends on how good
of a writer they are i mean i think
hegel is
kind of held back by the fact that he's
not a stylistically he's not that
that good of a writer compared to you
know say nietzsche or
schopenhauer people like that um
also say that a good bit of um
late 20th century french philosophy is
over complicated um
you know a lot of word games going on
that don't need to be there
that kind of stand in the way but then
again you know i didn't write their
books so
um i i've only got one book and dairy
diet has who knows how many
so i don't know about that
all right ethie um do i think i'd be
well equipped to help somebody analyze
their moral theory and
and try to find potential holes in it um
yeah i mean i do that
that's part of what we do in
philosophical counseling which i've been
carrying on since 2014
so going on seven years now um
that's also what we do in consulting
work sometimes you know like
working with corporations on on their
ethics stuff
um so yeah i think i'd be equipped to it
um to do it and i use resources from
philosophy
and techniques ronaldo asked do i think
mcintyre's project succeeds do you think
do i believe that secular morality has
bad foundations
um so those are two totally disconnected
things
you know um mcintyre in and i've got the
book right here
and after virtue right um
he's not a religious thinker
he's advocating something like a return
to
some sort of aristotelianism broadly
speaking it's only in his later books
where you know he talks about tomism and
stuff like that and he's actually you
know he's pretty cagey about that when
you ask
like there's a great interview in
kinesis which was the uh
graduate journal of southern illinois
university carbondale i was on
the editorial staff of that and in it
they asked him why did you become a
catholic and he's like because the
sacraments are there
you know and when in discussions with
him he
he tends to think that um the idea that
you have to be
you know you have to be a christian or
something
in order to understand morality properly
he doesn't buy that
so i don't know how those are connected
for you in your head but
and what is mcintyre's project
[Music]
his project is to engage in cultural
critique to figure out where things went
wrong
and then to suggest some important
guidelines and do a whole bunch of other
things along the way like you know say
don't have too much faith in
social science and that's something he
was doing way back
before after virtue
so is his project successful i'd say
that part of it is successful
was he supposed to buy his writing
produce some
massive new effect within
civil society i don't think he thought
that that's what his writing was
automatically
going to do so it all depends on what
you mean by
his project and how we want to see it as
successful
all right um well here's a here's a
really interesting set of questions from
tyson
who are the philosophers that were doing
similar type of work as wittgenstein but
are more informed and have greater
potential for doing something with their
philosophy
are there any philosophers that have
similar parallels to what the ordinary
language philosophers were doing
so i would say um that
you know let's confine ourselves to
talking about the middle to late
wittgenstein not the tractatus
wittgenstein because
yeah there's plenty of people doing that
sort of stuff the vienna circle you know
anybody who like thinks that symbolic
logic is is you know
basically how we describe the the
universe because a good portion of the
trucktatus is just like
outlining um a theory of
logic and its application to the world
into language
but if we're thinking about the
wittgenstein who's interested in forms
of life and language games
and you know how we make sense of things
and taking what we call the linguistic
turn yeah there's there's a lot of
people who are doing
interesting similar connected projects
one of them i would mention is john
wisdom right i keep talking about him
over and over again
in these things he was an analytic
philosopher who also thought it was
important to read
outside of just english philosophy
or outside of you know logic stuff and
so he
you know he's got some very interesting
reflections on
religion on um
uh freudianism on
john pulsart and existentialism um
and there's there's people who studied
with wittgenstein or influenced by
wittgenstein but then
extended it into other areas as well but
then you know in continental philosophy
there's all sorts of people that are
interested in language and its
connections with
community power things like that
paul recore would be a prime example of
somebody who
has a continental philosopher very well
read
also engaged with um analytic philosophy
in important ways
um you know uh
leotard actually uh takes some ideas
from wittenstein
and applies them in in his work um
but that's a good question i mean who
else who else should come to mind i mean
there's earlier
writers who are also interested in in
language
it's it's a very it's not like
wittgenstein discovered
the importance of language in shaping
our world that
is something that's already there in
some of the philosophers of the 18th
century
a 19th century like may you know um
haman for example you know or i mean we
could all go all the way back to vico
too
right um in the early modern period
so you know yeah i think there's there's
um
there's quite a few people that are
doing similar things to wittgenstein
vickenshine i think is is quite often
doing interesting stuff but a lot of the
time you're
you're it's almost like watching
somebody in a movie where you're like
don't go in there
hey the thing you want is over there you
know if
you you can you can see like an
uncertainty for example
so many paragraphs to to get to the the
insights that he has
you know so all right uh
sunny what is post modernism um
that's not something that has a simple
answer i mean why don't you get yourself
uh leotards the postmodern condition and
read your way through that and then see
what you think of it
i'll tell you what it's not it's not
something simple that you can
easily summarize and then say oh
there's postmodernism here and
post-modernism there the word has
all sorts of meanings it's been you know
kicking around since the 1970s as far as
i know
and you know it's a term that we
probably should be
suspect when people use a lot of the
time
um pasta says
any tensions and epictetus between
passages with an intellectualist view
like the medea example versus others
put emphasis on practice as if knowledge
alone is insufficient
no because epictetus doesn't have an
intellectualist view i i
i'm not even sure what you mean by that
because that can mean a million
different things right
but if you if you think that there's
there's that epictetus
taking you know a few things out of out
of uh
context and saying you know these
passages outlined over here have an
intellectualist view
i mean the medea thing i don't see that
as having
anything that corresponds to what i
would call an intellectualist view
medea is brought up precisely for two
reasons one is
as an example of somebody whose um
you know emotional state overrides
her um what she knows she ought to do
right my thumbos is what i'm going to
listen to and then he also says hey by
the way
you who get pissed off at medea look at
yourself
i don't see that as particularly
intellectualist
um but let's say it was then you you
contextualize it within the
larger um philosophy that we have in
epictetus you know
all right um
oh it just skipped let me get back to
here
um
there's a lot of questions
uh god word podcast so much of
professionalism is total bs
how can i get and hold down a job even
though it seems fake and upside down
yeah that that's quite true there's a
lot of things that you do
you know so here's here's part of what
my my experience
you're right a lot of things that we
call professionalism uh
in in like philosophy or in in fields in
general turns out to be
stuff that doesn't really matter and
doesn't get what we want in the first
place and it's a way of
you know kind of engaging in social
control and the worst is
there's a tendency for we ourselves to
buy into it
and become ourselves policers of it and
then policing ourselves and making us
feel bad you know
i mean there there are some things that
do fit into what
what people call professionalism that i
think are
less about professionalism and more
about not being a jerk
like you know following up on
correspondence which i'm not always
great with by
the way sometimes it takes me longer
than i want to respond to emails or they
they get you know buried beneath a whole
bunch of other emails
you know i have to like write somebody
and say oh i'm so sorry for
taking so long to get get back to you um
i don't have any good excuse for this um
but that's le that's not really about
professionalism and that's more about
just being a decent
person if somebody talks to you and you
want to be
you know good to them you should talk
back right there's a lot of other things
like
do you need to wear a dress shirt oh
here's a great example do you need to
wear a dress shirt not
in the classroom on a zoom call with
your colleagues
or when you're teaching or i mean this
is where things get really crazy there
are there are professors
who are insisting that every student on
their zoom
you know class sessions not only has the
camera on
but is dressed up you know and i look at
that and i'm like
that's not professionalism that's just
being a jerk to your students
why would you impose that on them you
know um oh because we're gonna you know
stress to them the importance of the the
workplace and and
how to be what a a really
um you know well put together
person i don't know that that's really
i don't know that's reflective of that
so yeah i i'd agree with you a lot of
professionalism
is bs um
[Music]
and a lot of it is tied to very
arbitrary stuff you know
it's and it's it's used to bash people a
lot of the time
um
gamut says i've been going through the
republic i wonder why you think plato's
socrates says a king that makes mistakes
is not a king
doctor making a mistake is isn't a
doctor it's actually through
semiconductors who says that right
rather than rather than plato himself so
i think that's that's the key there um
misha which philosophers do you think
have the best take on
existential anxiety also do you agree
that one should entertain their
anxiety i'm not sure what entertain
anxiety means
should you take your anxiety seriously
is that is that what it means because if
that's the case then
yeah in certain respects i mean a lot of
things were anxious about
not to be really worth being anxious
about
we do you know the people that are
here's a great example
you know the the people that are
worried about um cancel culture
and mr potato head you know being male
or female
or the dr seuss estate uh you know
not republishing six books um
those things are total [ __ ] nobody
nobody should give a [ __ ] about any of
that stuff
right now when we have uh
even before covet let's let's let's put
kobit aside which is still a major major
issue
we had incredible political polarization
we have incredible inequities within our
society
we are moving towards more and more
environmental crisis if you're not
focused on that stuff
and worried about those sorts of things
as well as the you know the
day-to-day things like how am i going to
hold down my job how am i going to keep
you know
house and home together are bad things
going to happen to me
and you're more worried about trivial
[ __ ] like you know
essentially culture matters of dr
seuss you've really got things backward
if if dr
seuss you know some books not being
republished
induces anxiety in you you're you're a
mess
and that is the case for a lot of people
right so we should be
we should be okay with some degree of
what the existentialists call anxiety
which really has to do with our freedom
and with
um what we're going to make of it our
responsibility
um there is there's something to be said
for that right
a lot of the trivial [ __ ] we probably
shouldn't be
worried about that all right uh
johan was maurice blondell influenced by
platonic philosophy i mean in the sense
that
everybody's influenced by platonic
philosophy sure
if you want to know who he's influenced
by more i would look at the authors that
he brings up
more often it's not plato um he's he's
influenced by
aristotle and plato and the medievals
who he was one of the first people to
actually teach in the french academy by
the way before jill sohn did
in his classes um he's influenced by
you know all sorts of uh christian
thinkers he's influenced by
his readings of modern thinkers like
descartes and kant and hegel
he's his hegel is not the phenomenology
it's mostly the logic that he read
he's influenced by henry newman he's
influenced by amanda b wren he's
influenced by
um pascal he's influenced by leibniz we
wrote one of his dissertations on so
yeah he's he's influenced by a whole
bunch of people and he's doing his own
kind of unique thing as well
all right uh andrew why do i think
dostoevsky wrote philosophical fiction
instead of non-fiction
i don't know it's a good good question
i guess he liked writing fiction you
know and he thought that he could do the
sort of things
that he wanted to do writing that and
also
you know another thing is you could
write serialized fiction and stay
just ahead of your uh your creditors
with the vast gambling debts that you
built up by
you know writing things in serial form
but i think he was drawn to the idea of
having characters who would
would you know raise issues and express
things um i mean
why did why did philip k dick write
fiction instead of uh
writing philosophy or why did you know
somebody we're going to again
talk about this month why did r scott
backer drop out of
vanderbilt uh not finish his
dissertation and instead
uh write his second apocalypse seven
book series of
of works along with things well he has
also done some academic philosophy on
the side and
consciousness stuff um
you know because you can uh you can have
characters like
work thoughts out i think there's
something about that
by the way i'm not somebody who does
that um i don't i've never
really i have tried my hand at writing
stories back when i was an undergraduate
but i haven't done it for a long time
and i don't think the stories i wrote
were particularly good back then
they're all probably lost so i wrote
them on a typewriter at that time
all right um lord roku i'm pretty sure
that you've read ecclesiastes
what are your thoughts on the philosophy
that it gets expounded in there
that's a good question a lot of people
read the book of ecclesiastes
uh and they're like oh it's just
pessimism
you know but when you read you read
further on into the work
right and it still holds that there is
there might not be an afterlife but
there is still good and bad
and we still should you know like do
things the right way
um that's an interesting point of view
within that that text
uh alberto opinion on jethro tull
um definitely not metal um despite the
grammys awarding them
uh a metal grammy
which is kind of a travesty i like
jethro tull um
and you know i think they're good to
listen to they're they're
interesting prague rock basically uh
heavy rock
but um not metal so
um let's see here
edmund what what concepts if any would
you say are lost or commonly
misunderstood in translation from
epictetus
i don't know if anything's lost in
translation
uh what are some ideas that are
misunderstood the dichotomy of control
a lot of people are like that's the
centerpiece of stoicism and that's wrong
that's just one idea uh one helpful set
of practices
it's not the centerpiece the linchpin of
stoicism
it's one out of many important ideas
that you find in there
um i would say that there's not enough
emphasis
on how it is that pro-erasis
uh determines itself and develops itself
prior racist is the faculty of choice a
lot of people get mixed up
they think that the faculty of choice or
the will
sometimes translated as and the rational
faculty and the ruling faculty are
different things
i would say an epictetus they're not
actually
and he is the person who talks the most
about the
faculty of choice prior races in order
to understand what priorisis means for
epictetus you have to read epictetus
you cannot begin by just looking at
aries didymus or diogenes lairtase where
it says pro-racist is choice before a
choice because
that is definitely not an adequate
characterization of it
um what else in epictetus um i mean
habit is
incredibly important in epictetus
the notion of the indifference the
externals
he is totally crystal clear over and
over again that
um they strictly speaking around outside
of our control but our use of them the
way that we deal with them is in our
control
right so that extends that whole
dichotomy of control thing in important
ways
beyond what you get in you know um
encouraging one
and discourses one one so those are some
those are a couple uh examples
liquid has a very difficult to answer
question
what is your take on contemporary
philosophers are there any you recommend
there is such a vast field of
contemporary philosophers people
are often like hey have you have you
read this guy have you heard of this
person over here and i'll be like
like with aristotle scholarship somebody
had a comment on one of my videos
recently where they're like i really
like so-and-so's take on
on this in aristotle's politics and i
was like
buddy there's like you know 10 000
people you could you could recommend
i haven't read this person you know um
[Music]
you know and i'm somebody who actually
does does work on aristotle
there's there's so many interesting
people out there
i'm actually going to turn the question
on its head i'm going to say
don't worry so much about people doing
like
original work you know the new minds of
the the century or something like that
and look at the people who are doing
work that's engaged with
other philosophers and making something
out of them you know they have some
interesting interpretations like
again i'll mention somebody who i'm
really fond of both as a person
and as a scholar my colleague chris gill
you know um he's got you know a lot of
works out i enjoy reading his his works
um he is making original points but he's
usually making it in relation to like
what the stoics are saying or what you
know hellenistic
philosophy is about um he's not trying
to like forge a whole new path
himself and i think that for me i like
that
you know i like i like having
conversations about these
other uh thinkers
all right uh here's a question from may
april
why would you let anyone no matter how
big the name has influenced you
uh they don't live your experience
philosophy is just one big story with
many directions and many authors
well you let people influence you
because you're open to being influenced
by other people because that's a good
thing
because that's that's part of what the
way that we learn as human beings you
know
um i'm i'm influenced by all sorts of
philosophers you know i don't think
that's a bad thing
right um
steve says uh it was kind of cryptic
comment aristotle says animals
are souls i eat cats and dogs well they
have souls right
uh yeah but soul means something
different in aristotle than it does say
for you know
christian theologians or somebody like
that although you know aquinas of course
buys into that they just have animal
souls um
reuben i find confusing the opposites
argument in fedo
plato himself says the world there's no
perfection there for no perfect symmetry
so of course everything will come either
from something bigger smaller than
itself
uh yeah okay um
i don't think that the i don't think
that the opposites is saying that things
are coming from the forms themselves
right
he's just talking about how opposition
works
um stacy asks what do i think of alvin
plantinga
um you know i think he's he's an
interesting person i've seen him speak
before
i think that you know people i think
that
he's essentially an analytic philosopher
of religion
um i i you know
i can't think of anything that he's done
or said where
i was like wow that is amazing you know
first
rate he certainly held his in very high
esteem within certain
uh christian philosophical circles um
but you know one of the problems is he
so he wrote some interesting things on
christian philosophy
and he in effect retraced but not in as
good of a way
what what people in these long debates
that i do research on
had been saying about it since the 50s
and and this is one of the problems with
the analytic philosophy in general
is they don't do enough reading of of
other people
and so they recreate something and it's
usually not going as deep
and you know you uh this kind of goes to
the wittgenstein question earlier too
you know you don't always have to
reinvent the wheel you know
all right um mason what can
stoicism offer to someone who loses a
loved one
um it's not going to offer anything
right off the bat
like you know you you lose somebody and
then you're like oh i better go get some
stoic literature so i can make myself
feel better
it's like anything else you have to have
been practicing it for a while just like
if you
you know don't lift weights or exercise
or anything like that and then you get
thrown into a situation where you need
to
to do some physical things you're not
gonna just by being handed a bunch of
weights you're not going to be up to the
challenge
um i suppose for somebody who has no
encounter with it
maybe a few stoic dogmata might be
helpful but
they're probably not going to be all
that helpful instead it's something that
you want to do
before you lose the loved one right and
then i think one of the most useful
things about it so there's this passage
in epictetuses and coridian
where he says um you know when you kiss
your wife or child
remind yourself of what they are so that
when they die you're not going to be so
upset
and people are like well that sucks
stoics are
you know really uh heartless bastards
right and
the the beginning of the passage says
for anything that you
find useful or that you
feel affection towards philosophy right
and that includes the wife and child or
whoever you know could be my
my cat over there who's slowly dying of
uh
we found out bladder cancer 18 years old
one of the things that comes out of epic
thinking about epictetus's stuff
people think that if you're not like
showing visible signs of grief or not
getting upset
that you didn't really love the person
and those are disconnected
you can you can love the person that
doesn't mean
that you have to feel as if the whole
world has come to an
end because they're gone you know you
can still like
honor them and you know go over the
memories
now that said it doesn't mean that we
have to like just reject sadness or
anything like that i mean
i'm still sad about um missing my
mom and dad who you know one of whom
died uh 20 years ago the other one died
when i was just a kid
um i i you know sometimes grieve the
missed opportunities there's things that
i would like to
talk with them about you know as my own
kids are
are growing into adults um but it
doesn't have to be so
so overwrought emotionality right
we haven't we have some choice in the
matter we can
we can direct our our selves and we can
you know engage in self scrutiny and
figure out which emotional responses
make sense and which which are kind of
excessive
you know we can uh we can do things
about that
shulgi asked what is my view on eastern
philosophy is there a chance we could
get a lecture analysis on the channel
about it are you centered on western
philosophy so i'll say there's no such
thing as eastern philosophy
and i think that talking about it in
those ways is
actually counterproductive and kind of
you know it's it's often indulgent
western philosophy is itself incredibly
rich
and vast and we should talk instead
about comparative philosophy
and we should talk about particular
cultural spheres
so there's there's you know chinese
philosophy
and then the other areas that were
particularly particularly impacted by
chinese culture like japan korea
vietnam that is its own sphere
with its own stuff going on that's as
different
from indian philosophy as it is from
uh you know say early modern
um uh philosophy
like you know descartes or things like
that and yet there'll be parallels
between them
and there's a lot of commonalities
between what's going on in
ancient greek and roman philosophy and
what's happening in chinese philosophy
you know
um and we can so we can talk about
cultural spheres we can talk about the
chinese cultural sphere we can talk
about the indian subcontinent
we can talk about the entire islamic
world and all these interpenetrate each
other
and then we can talk about other things
that we can say are they
are they philosophy are they not there's
there's debate to be had
but i am willing to let them in the door
um
i focus mostly on on you know the stuff
that i can
be very competent in because i know the
languages i don't i don't read classical
chinese
so i'm at a disadvantage in talking
about menses or
um you know about later
neo-confucianism or anything like that i
mean i teach classes on it but i
i don't shoot a lot of content because
there's other people out there who can
do that
you know i don't have to do everything
even within western philosophy if we're
going to call it that
just call it european philosophy i don't
i don't
tackle every single author it may look
like that but for me
from my perspective there's all these
big gaps um
so you know i i try to stick to what i
what i can do best
i certainly have a lot of respect for
those who can read
poly or sanskrit or japanese or
you know and read these texts and
i think you know it's it's good to know
your limitations
um sergey says when it comes to
unpleasant emotions like anxiety you
think you should
strive to reduce them as much as humanly
possible or do you think it's about
feeling them at appropriate times and
amounts
it depends on the emotion i mean
with anxiety the modality of fear
right i i mean even the stoics say
there's rational fear
they call that ulabeia caution right um
there's other emotions like envy i don't
think there's ever really any good envy
you know um when people say oh yeah but
what if it leads you to do good things
yeah so something bad led you to do
something good doesn't make it
necessarily good
what about emulation well that's
different aristotle
already saw that from envy you know um
so i think there can be some where we we
do want to try to
reduce we probably can't get rid of them
all together we probably want to reduce
them as much as possible
and then there's others where it is
really about feeling them at appropriate
times and amounts you know
um you don't have to be an aristotelian
to see that
um all right
uh let's see here
is nietzsche the worst philosopher no
it's easy to answer
uh pointsman any thoughts on solomon
maimon
um i haven't read him so nothing i can i
can say
about him um
marquette cowley says are there any
stoic books for kids to lay a foundation
also what's the story about your
pendleton sweater i
assume you mean by that the dude sweater
right so
uh you know when i first started
teaching and recording my
my videos um and i let my hair grown out
grow out people are like it looks like
the dude is teaching philosophy so it
became kind of a running joke
and years back my wife bought me that
sweater
as you know for for christmas as as a
a kind of gag gift in a way and it's
very comfortable and it's really
nice to to have so i i wear it around
and
i've always wanted to do like some
videos where i'll let my hair down and
take the glasses off and like you know
talk in the the idiom of the dude
so that's the story behind that are
there any stoic books for kids
that's a good question i don't know of
any quite frankly
and that would be a really interesting
challenge how do you write a book that's
going to be oriented towards kids
and not like totally water things down
and and make it work um
there is a stoicism and parents facebook
group
i would actually and i'm a member of it
um
i would actually check them out and i
would ask them that question
there in the group once you become a
member because they they probably would
would know
way better than i would
all right
let's see who else we got here um
oh here's a good question meta
procrastinator what are some must reads
before starting on heidegger's being in
time
yeah that's a good question i mean there
are some things by heidegger you could
read
um i think i always start my students
off on what is metaphysics
and i've got some good resources for
that uh that are that are
available both podcasts and videos
and that kind of gives you some of you
know heidegger's big themes ahead of
time
um it's good to know some kant i would
definitely say
i don't think you have to actually read
his role before reading heidegger's
being in time
um
he's mentioning descartes he's
mentioning aristotle he's mentioning
plato so you probably want to have some
good
good uh you know some good readings of
those
under your belt um
it is the kind of work too i'll mention
where
you're gonna go at it and it you know
it's it's very technical he's forming
his own vocabulary
in it uh and sometimes he doesn't tell
you at the start with like the antic
ontological
uh distinction right article
and ontological he just invokes it at
the beginning without telling you what
the hell it means
later on in the work you kind of get
some stuff about that um
yeah all right um
let's see here duke duke says happy
saturday what would you say are the
biggest differences between classical
platonism
and neoplatonism they're both classical
platonism right they're both from the
classical
period diving into the nands recently
so there's there's there's platonism in
in like you know plato himself
and then there's all these
interpretations that form what we call
middle platonism
and though those emerge eventually into
what we call neoplatonism
and you know neoplatonism is platonism
in that it's involving a re-reading
of the platonic
text and trying to systematize what
plato himself didn't systematize
it's also as is is middle platonism and
when i say middle platonism i mean
people like um
plutarch is a prime example um
they're bringing in insights sometimes
from the stoics and from the
aristotelians
and so that's that's obviously not there
in plato because there's no stoic
there's no aristotelians in plato's
texts right
um and it's kind of interesting who who
are the really faithful platonists
are they the people who confine
themselves to plato's texts
well i think what you're calling here
classic platonus or are they the people
who are trying to make sense out of a
platonic perspective
within a world that includes other
perspectives
and new ideas you know there's also we
can talk about
pagan neoplatonism we can talk about
jewish neoplatonism with like filo of
alexandria who's pretty eclectic
and then there's christian neoplatonism
as well
[Music]
one thing that you can say one really
key difference
plato never really resolved certain
issues within his works
so what is the nature of the soul he
never adequately clarifies it it's not a
form
it's something that can grasp the forms
well what the hell is it then it's a
reality that survives
indefinitely it's it's related to these
other things that are greater realities
right
what's the nature of the form of forms
the form beyond being the form of the
good
or the beautiful that's another issue
that's that's clarified i would say in
neoplatonism which plato you know he he
brings it up but he doesn't really
resolve it
you know so there there i would say
neoplatonism
there are it's the product of resolving
some issues that are being brought up
and then it's also done in sort of a
pedagogical um uh manner where like well
you should do things this way and
understand this first and all that
all right uh let's see um joshua says
what's my um opinion of albert camus the
rebel do i think kambu is a chilled out
version of nietzsche
no i think i think um kamu i mean kamu
talks about nietzsche doesn't he
so you could certainly um look at what
he has to say about about nietzsche
he he sometimes endorses him other times
doesn't
i think the rebels are great work um i'm
i
you know i like kamu quite a bit i don't
agree with him on some things but i can
go along his path quite a way
um don key says
drawing on my scholarship what might be
some abductive reasoning the stoics
could bring to us 21st century schizoid
people
as we work towards creating artificial
consciousness so a lot of stuff mixed in
there
i don't know that we're 21st century
schizoid people that's not
a way i would recognize myself
and um abductive reasoning abduction is
is you know often opposed to induction
and deduction it's also
sometimes called inference to the best
explanation and so you make kind of a
leap
um i don't know that the stoics would
would
be particularly
you could say this the stoics wouldn't
engage in abductive reasoning that has
to do with artificial
consciousness it's more like we could
draw upon some ideas from the stones and
say maybe we could
we could use this in some way um
you know maybe i'll give you one example
and this is something i
i don't have completely worked out i
need to do some still more thinking
about
so the stoics think as i mentioned
earlier
that there's an interconnection between
volition and the grasp of values
and cognition and we can frame this in
terms of the
pro races or faculty of choice
uh or the volontas right if we're
looking at at
seneca and the uh
rational faculty the the logic
right and these are both dimensions
of the ruling faculty the hegemony cone
which can take on all these different
modifications you if you're a stoic you
actually feel your emotions in the
hegemonic
it's not like you have a separate part
of yourself i do have to say seneca
sometimes talks
along the platonic lines but for the
most part the orthodox stoic position is
you actually feel your emotions in your
hegemony cone
part your ruling part and
so that might be
you know that might be a useful model
for trying to think about
artificial consciousness that could
actually be
human-like in some way i don't i don't
know
um
[Music]
are there any other things that's a good
question i'd have to think about that
more
it's kind of an interesting issue to
bring up
um robert connor
uh what are your thoughts on
christianity these days i mean not much
different than others i think a lot of
christians like
throughout history or not particularly
good representatives of the ideals of
the religion but that's always been the
way it's been right
a lot of discussions here about
black pills brown pills stuff like that
all right
let's see who do we have that hasn't
said something
uh suburban legend is modern science
more aristotelian or platonic
neither it's its own thing and uh
there's no such thing as modern science
there's the
all these sciences and lots of different
theories and
approaches and stuff like that so
science itself is kind of a mess it's
not something to turn into
an idealized abstraction
um
let's see jean says uh
i was wondering if you have any thoughts
on boethius i enjoy his thought but i
don't see him being talked about much
i teach him actually in my classes i i
like boethius quite a bit
i think that one of the
real tragedies is that
he wasn't able to pull off his
translation project
because he got killed he was he he
wanted to translate all of plato and all
of aristotle
from greek into latin and he succeeded
in only translating a few volumes
before he was placed under house arrest
you think about how different
the intellectual environment of
western europe might have been prior to
the
you know the translation project carried
out in muslim spain
um if they'd had
like it's not that they didn't know
aristotle and plato because they still
had cicero
and seneca and you can get some good
summaries of things
in in those but they didn't have the
texts right so that would have been
pretty amazing if
if those hadn't been lost
uh rt whitby asked for aristotle what
was the relationship between being
knowledgeable and acting prudently
um well prudence is its own kind of
prudence for practical wisdom is its own
kind of you can call it knowledge if you
want it's a practical knowledge right
um a knowledge of what's good for us
what's good for human beings and then
it also helps us to like discern things
and when we're dealing with particulars
you also do need some background
knowledge like if you don't know that
that drinking you know
too much coffee is bad for you it's
going to be hard to make good decisions
and be prudent about it right
or if like you think that water is is
actually
likely to be contaminated with microbes
and you're like well i'm not going to
drink you know four of these
per day you're not going to be very
prudent right so there's a lot of
connections between those all right um
steve fitzpatrick can you explain the
philosophy of john locke
sure but not here right so
um cola moose says i'm having a hard
time with back or maybe i'm just biased
because i don't agree with them on stuff
but the beginning of the first book just
feels like people
being jerks to each other um well yeah
you are biased then
you know if you if you've got to be able
to distance
reading somebody from agreeing with them
that that's
i mentioned this at the beginning that's
that's a basic uh trait
or skill in philosophy but if if all
you're seeing is people being jerks to
each other
um there's way more going on in in there
so
i don't know what to tell you other than
you'd probably have to reread it
you know um so that's
it's unfortunate because rereading these
myself i'm like wow this is pretty
amazing stuff um
all right anastasia are there any real
bases for seeing analytical philosophy
superior to continental philosophy i've
seen that point of view quite often
there never have been and analytic
philosophy
doesn't mean the same thing today as it
did 30 years ago
as it did in its inception i mean most
most people who talk about you know an
analytic approach today
we often talk about post analytic
because they've lost any
mooring in their their you know original
roots
um and continental philosophy names a
whole bunch of different approaches
which are often quite mutually hostile
to each other
so you know no there's there's no
there's no real basis
for seeing either of those is superior
to each other
and there's no real basis for seeing
them as the
the main approaches of philosophy either
all right um i'm going to skip
down a bit uh
and grab some from people who i haven't
already taken questions from
so noah asked about chad a hog
um and his largely negative view of
contemporary academic philosophy
i don't know who he is but i'm sure
there's probably lots and lots of people
out there who
you know are asking or putting forth
similar critiques
it's kind of a cottage industry matthew
hopkins i'm reading a lot of the
empiricists at the moment their work all
seems to broadly follow a similar
pattern
starting with the psychology and
epistemology then moving on to ethics
i struggle to see how they bridge the
gap between the psychology and ethics
and this seems to be very fundamental in
hobbs and lock so hobbes is not an
empiricist
hobbs is actually very rationalist in
many ways
locke there's a good bit of rationalism
in him as well
um they they do focus on uh
psychology i mean with hobbes the
psychology is pretty short
uh and then he's jumping into his his
political theory which occupies the rest
of
well it occupies most of uh book one and
pretty much all of book two
and then you get the weird wacky crap of
three or four in the leviathan that
nobody reads because it's just
his theology um
i don't think there's a gap that has to
be bridged right it's so it's not like
it's not like first somebody's doing
epistemology and then only afterwards
doing ethics
they make epistemological points which
have ethical implications within certain
you know
frameworks that that's pretty
straightforward uh hume
you know you look at the treaties and
two-thirds of the two of the books of
the treaties are really devoted to
essentially ethical topics right um
now he'll break it down into two
different inquiries but even the
the inquiry has a lot of implications
for ethics as well
so i'm not i'm not sure i'm seeing the
problem there
it might be that you're you're demanding
too much
of this bridging the gap or something
like that so
you you probably want to abandon that
metaphor
and then go back at the texts and say
how how are these positions leading to
the
the ethics that they have and unlock
doesn't have an awful lot of ethics
humans a lot more
you could say right um
ellsworth says is all of near future
philosophy going to be in chinese in
hindi
why would that be the case i mean
hopefully a lot more of it will be
but um it's not like we stopped speaking
english
or french or spanish or german or you
know like nobody can write any
philosophy in russian
or in any other languages
it could be kind of cool if we have more
translation back and forth that would be
that would be very nice but
that's tough to pull off translation is
a thankless task you can say
um
all right
champion of wits i found nietzsche very
inspiring and insightful can you
recommend me others like him
you know it depends on what you're
getting out of nietzsche
doesn't it because if it's um
like the critique of culture and the
worries about nihilism
and you know the perspectivalism
that then there's some people you could
recommend if it's like
everyone needs to dominate everybody or
you're a you're a loser and nobody
well there would be other other um
thinkers that you would recommend then
if it's the
uh kind of um unnecessary
racism and stuff like that there'd be
yet other thinkers
that you could you could recommend um so
you know
if you're if you're into let's say i'll
say the stuff that that's the best in
nietzsche
uh other existentialists are are doing
people that you know saw connections
between him and others like
li lev chest off right or uh miguel de
una muno people who i've done
videos on in recent years because i
think that their work
needs to be better appreciated um
you could you could go backwards and
look at if you like aphoristic stuff
lichtenberg has got some kind of cynical
views on things
um
you know it's always worth reading
anitra was closely associated with lou
andreas solomon it's worth reading her
stuff
that's that's about nietzsche that's
kind of interesting as well
corby what do i think about friedrich
jameson and his contributions to
literary criticism
you know jameson is interesting to read
um
he can often be great at like filling in
gaps for you he's a good person to read
and not because he makes some really
important novel contributions of his own
but he's like
he's like a person who tells useful
narratives and directs you
at things quite quite helpfully i would
say
um ivan my opinion as a philosophy
professor on the usefulness of studying
and teaching history
um well i mean it all depends on how
you're teaching the history right
i i would say and this is sort of a
thing people who bill themselves as
being history buffs just as much as
people who call themselves political
junkies
usually only know like the little sliver
and it's very ideological
um teaching history in a real sense is
is
tough to do you have to bring in lots
and lots of voices and perspectives and
find ways to
sort through them i think that
understanding history is very important
to
understanding philosophy not not just
because
you want to locate the philosophers in
their context but also because
we are historical creatures right um
and getting yourself away from certain
kinds of uh
prevalent but [ __ ] histories is
often very useful like the
um thing that kind of dominated you know
from hegel onward for a long time of you
know it's really plato and aristotle who
are the
the the most important thinkers and they
were working in a time when the greek
city-states still matter and then philip
of macedon comes along
and you know unites greece and we get
the alexandrian empire and everything's
kind of going downhill from there it's
all
second rate after that you look at that
and you're like
wow that that is a stretch man given
what we know
um there's some really great philosophy
in there that that will lead you to
totally ignore um so
you know having the right kind of
history is kind of kind of important
uh william evans uh asked my thoughts on
aleister crowley's magical philosophy my
impressions of crowley
uh same as it was back when we talked
about this
years ago i'm not i'm not particularly
interested in crowley
so
we're getting a little bit close to end
time so i'm gonna i'm gonna
add some i'm gonna try to add voices in
here that haven't
had anything and start picking some easy
to answer questions let's see what we
got
scrolling down um
a lot of back and forth with people
chatting with each other here
um
oh here's an interesting point uh
responding to one of the questions it
was asked
ryan holiday just wrote an all ages book
about marcus aurelius as a child
could be good could be drivel i don't
know you know
somebody else would have to read it and
weigh in on it
um well seeking truth here's an easy one
why is the left so morally and
intellectually bankrupt workness and
wisdom are incompatible
um i would say that's that's uh
wrong on many counts so but you know you
might you might take the time to like
rethink your assumptions and
why you thought you wanted to broadcast
that sort of stuff
here as if um you know that was that was
some sort of wisdom itself
um let's see here
[Music]
oh here's a i'm scared to read hegel
is he the hardest philosopher to read in
your opinion
he's he's tough uh he's harder in some
books than he is in others
there's no reason to be scared to read
somebody i mean
if you think about our emotions right
it makes sense to be scared when um
something happens to you like you find
out that you might have been poisoned
right
reading a book should never be a scary
experience because what's the book going
to do bite you
make fun of you you know there's nothing
a book can actually
do to you that if you are thinking
things through clearly
would impact your physical being
or even your psychological well-being i
mean
unless you chose to read a book that was
like you suck you suck you suck i mean
that's kind of a boring book i mean
you might be scared that you're you're
wasting your time but that's a fear not
about the book but about wasting your
time and you can think about all the
stuff you you also spend time on
um and if you think that hegel's scary
read you know read somebody else i guess
you know there's there's so many other
people
that you have available to you you might
feel as if like you're letting yourself
down if you don't read hegel
um or maybe you have to present hegel to
somebody that could be scary right if
you don't feel that you fully understand
it
but you can just come out and say here's
the best that i
here's the best ideas that i have you
know
um all right let's see here
here's an interesting question um
from ivan thoughts on today's rise of
popularity of internet astrology on the
one hand and the other personality tests
of jungian types
and maybe in relation to adorno's view
on the occult and culture
i i don't think it has much to do with
the dorno's views
adorno is not a you know future
predictor
i don't know that there's more interest
in astrology
at this point in time than there was 10
years ago
20 years ago there's always people
interested in that i mean you can you
get your horoscopes in the newspaper
personality tests seem to have been very
popular since
you know we started having social media
people would always be reporting about
their myers-briggs stuff
or taking when facebook first came out
there all these tests that you could
take
where they're really data harvesting use
i don't know that i don't know that
there's a fundamental
new thing about that there's always been
people who are
looking for
simplistic but sophisticated sounding
solutions for understanding themselves
and understanding the world and i would
say that those sorts of matters
appeal to to that right
so yeah
all right um oh here's a really
interesting question
favorite character from any novel or a
character
you identify yourself with
i don't i don't know that i have a
favorite character
from any particular novel i have lots
and lots of characters who i
i like in certain ways and identify with
um you know i
i don't know there are characters that i
can more
identify with than others in the sense
of
like agreeing with more or seeing more
of myself
in them i think in the past
you know i would read stuff like say
philip jose farmer
and there would be these characters who
are like almost like nietzsche and
supermen right
where they're in super great shape and
they've acquired all these combat
skills and they speak different
languages and
um you know they're they're
intellectually gifted
and they're usually the hero i mean this
would be like a evan votes
um you know world of knowledge gilbert
gosse is kind of like that
or uh in the world of tears
or you know these characters along those
lines that's what i
i wanted to be like you know and then i
don't know how it happened but over time
i
i just kind of got not quite so
interested in that maybe it's you know
life wearing you down and realizing
you're never gonna
be somebody like that um
you know and that uh it's sometimes more
interesting to see what
regular people are are doing and
grappling with
but that's a really great question i
think that's that's one that a lot of
people could ask themselves you know
um
all right uh here's a one from august
dennis
haven't watched your live stream updates
in a long while just stop by to say i
started up a group to watch and work
through your half hour hegel series well
that's very nice um
i would be interested to learn how
how it works do the do the videos
actually help you out or do they wind up
being an obstacle
um you know i i i when i started doing
it i
didn't really know what what the effects
were going to be and it's always good to
get some like
you know some feedback on that that sort
of stuff
um but that's kind of cool um i i did
intend for the series
to help people get into the
phenomenology which is a difficult work
and you know not to supplement not to
replace
um reading it but to help people
you know eventually the the series
itself should be like one of those you
know ladders to be thrown away once
you've climbed up there right it should
hopefully allow you to read hegel more
and i want to do this with other
thinkers too i've done this with
epictetus and the end encouraging
same half hour thing um turned it into a
whole course a free course that's in my
study with sadler academy i want to do
that with you know rene descartes
meditations and the
replies and objections and i want to do
that with
anselm's prosologian maybe some other
other works as well we'll see
all right
vedic aryan says i joined for the first
time what's the agenda for discussion
it's an ama
that means they ask me anything there
doesn't have an agenda
right so ah here's a great question
from liv uh do you think it's right for
some universities to completely emit
freud his contributions the way we think
about psychology seems fundamental
yet people dismiss him because he wasn't
always right this is a great example
of throwing out the baby with the
bathwater right
so freudianism itself became like the
ruling orthodoxy
in in a lot of american psychology
for quite a long time and it stifled
innovation
and growth and other theories and so
it you know pre created some some beefs
or bad blood you can say
and so that that's a problem on the one
hand and
on the other hand there's this tendency
to say oh freud is
all totally wrong i mean nobody can be
totally wrong
it's all you know pseudoscience yeah we
don't have to think of it necessarily as
science we could look at some of it as
you know useful in certain respects
the idea of doing depth psychology and
investigating trauma it doesn't have to
be done in exactly the same way that
freud does
and we don't have to like buy into the
oedipus complex which is pretty
implausible
um but you know we can still study him
i'm
i'm when i'm teaching my philosophies of
human nature
uh class this semester we're going to
read some freud from his introductory
lectures to psychoanalysis
in part because he's had some important
cultural influence and it's good to know
what he actually thought we didn't just
like we don't have to study
um we'd have to be cartesians to see
some value in studying descartes you
know
so yeah
um let's see what else have we got
to do
well here's a here's an interesting
political question um
yeah we'll probably close on wearing a
mask in public spaces to protect others
is a simple request how can we draw on
philosophy to help sort out this debate
i hope society would be more cohesive
concerning public health so
we're not going to be able to draw on
philosophy to solve this debate because
the people who are
anti-mask when you look at what's going
on and the justifications that they give
and the affects that they show
they're not people for the most part
that just philosophy by itself is going
to reach
there's a lot of anxiety and anger
and like weird reaching out for crazy
conspiracy
stuff you know the government is trying
to tyrannize us even among here in
wisconsin like our supreme court
justices
some of them are clearly nut jobs you
know uh claiming that that
you know a mask mandate is tyranny it's
a small thing you know to put it on
and these people getting hysterical oh
it's keeping me from being able to
breathe you know
you're like come on snowflake uh just
put it on
don't be a jerk you know even if even if
it's like uh
coronavirus theater that's not killing
you to do it
you know the fact that people think that
this is such a
um hill to die on for them
and they're just not going to cooperate
with it it's a sign that there's some
serious mental illness out there i would
say
it's not just a matter of ideology
there's there's some real problems and
and these are problems that are often
generated by the very people that those
people will vote for
i don't know that philosophy is going to
help as
philosophy it's certainly something that
we talk about a lot in my philosophy
classes and i can tell you that that
you know my students for the most part
as younger people
have very little tolerance for the older
people the boomers
and you know people out in this in you
know the
suburban areas who think that this is
all about their freedom
they they they get pretty angry about
that because they're like
we'd like to get this over with so we
can get back to you know something
that's uh just normal levels of screwed
upness for us
you know so you know i think that that's
a good way to
to look at the issue we can use
philosophy to we can use you know being
prudent
on our own um we probably also want to
think about where
we can um
[Music]
you know just by modeling being a
rational person slowly bring others back
into the fold but
it's not as if there aren't going to be
foolish selfish people
out there who want to take a stand on on
this particular thing
notice too that a lot of them are very
inconsistent they won't wear a mask but
they want the vaccine
you know because it's not a problem and
then it is a problem you know or they
they don't
want to wear a mask themselves but they
want everybody else to wear masks or
things like that
but you can think about that as typical
uh
human behavior in in many respects
that's fostered by
the wrong sort of notion of freedom
and we could do an analysis of that but
what's going to happen when you put that
analysis in somebody's face are they
going to automatically change their mind
not any more than they do on other moral
and political issues
so all right well that's a good place to
end and i'm going to say thanks to
everybody
i didn't get to everybody
who never do but we'll see you next time
around we have some other events coming
up this month that you might be
interested as well
and uh yeah we'll end it here i'll see
all of you later on